thousands of supporters of tunisia's
opposition Coalition have defied a
protest ban and are on the streets of
the capital Tunis they've broken through
a police barrier and that in the city's
Main Street they're demanding the
release of political prisoners trade
unionists and journalists president high
side dissolved parliament in 2021
elections in December were boycotted by
the opposition who accused him of a
paragraph we're going to bring in said
onisi she's a former member of tunisia's
parliament very good to have you with us
ma'am on Al Jazeera what's different
about these protests compared to the
ones that we've seen before
thank you very much
um what we can say is new in in Tunisia
in terms of opposition to the president
is actually the popularity of the
movements today is the second day of
demonstration uh yesterday was also a
very a very big and and intense day of
protesting
um the president high side and uh the
what we call to Denton is that the new
dictatorship uh which is being
established
um today again we are actually having
ourselves surprised by the popularity
the new kind of
um average citizens who are actually
protesting and are facing also the the
threats and the repression uh linked to
this decision to go out on the streets
and to go for freedoms and to go for
also the release as you said of
political prisoners because today
Justice in Tunisia is actually being
um deformed and uh being definitely used
by the president of hindsight against
his opponent in fake trials I mentioned
before the the protest that we're seeing
today
um apparently the crowds have broken
through a police barrier and there are
now on the Main Street of of Tunis I
want to ask you about the response of
the police and the military over the
last few weeks to these protests because
one would imagine in other countries
when you had crowds of this size that
there would be a military and police
Crackdown what does that tell you about
the position that the police in the
military are taking with regard to these
protests
I want to remain very cautious toward
that because let's not forget the fact
that the police in the military are
being used by the president
um you know to satisfy
um his own um authoritarian projects the
military is uh closing the parliament
since
um almost two years now the police has
killed and this is facts uh protesters
uh during a previous demonstrations in
Chinese and I'm thinking about
especially Elizabeth in January 2012. so
we are very very cautious towards that
we know that they will be arrest we know
that the demonstration today is actually
being banned and envisioned by the
governor authorities in in Tunis but in
the same time I'm very hopeful
um to the fact that the police actually
learned from the revolution the military
land from The Revolution and what is
important is to stick to um you know
people's rights and and people's also
desires for a world of flow kind of you
know system and and to respect people uh
it is not a criminal to demonstrate it
is not criminal to um actually go and
script of freedoms I really invite
everybody to listen to the shunts and
slogans today they are actually people
calling for democracy and despite this
term being unfashioned and despite all
the uh trials again and and at a very
difficult time Tunisia is going through
and also and this is important this is
not an elitist uh kind of demonstration
people are calling for economic reforms
accounting for uh you know social
reforms are calling for uh inflation to
be controlled by the state they are also
very concrete I would say demands coming
from the streets today is not and it's
very important to say in elitist
demonstration for people who are just
talking theoretically about democracy
today also we are hearing uh people uh
condemning Fascism and racism maybe
that's going through a very very
difficult time type of geopolitic in
Africa the president had a very harsh
words but against black immigrants in in
Tunisia Tunisia which has been a country
for decades which actually welcomed uh
thousands of uh
non-tennessee workers and today is
rhetoric which is and we know it very
well just a way of defense against all
the difficulties Tunisia is going
through because the president don't want
to address it or to address the fact
that dictatorship cannot and let me
forgive me for interrupting you but I do
want to ask you one thing very briefly
um there is it has to be acknowledged of
course that the president still has a
significant amount of support within
Tunisia How concerned are you that his
supporters are not being influenced by
the opposition protests that are
happening and in fact we may end up
seeing clashes on the streets between
supporters of the president and those of
the opposition
foreign
in a situation when you have a very deep
economic crisis and people are basically
fighting uh for their daily existence uh
in terms of uh social and economic
matters it's very actually easy to
spread misinformation at this
information and rumors lies and to uh
you know again kind of manipulate this
masses and this is not something which
is property tourism and it's actually
happening in Tunisia um in in the way uh
and just to speak about this last days
the fact that chimneys or a large party
of the public opinion got convinced by
the president that uh black migrant
Engineers are taking the jobs of
tunisians are actually those who are
responsible and behind the economic
crisis in Tunisia also say and and you
are definitely right in that that his
discourse and his uh you know uh
ideologies actually well spread also
imagination and what is happening is
that in the other way there is a
resistance to that there is people there
is political parties Civil Society
organizations as we said also yesterday
um who are resisting to that and and
trying also to counter is discourse so
then they said we appreciate you being
with us and Al Jazeera thank you very
much indeed
thank you